[Música]
redada a Israel y al campamento
palestino de jenning en las discordaña
ocupada
9 palestinos muertos
atentados cerca de una sinagoga en
Jerusalén este siete israelíes muertos
cohetes palestinos lanzados contra
Israel desde gaza
bombardeos israelíes en represalia en
unos pocos días el conflicto palestino
israelí ha vuelto a escalar desde el
levantamiento Popular palestino de mayo
de 2021 las tensiones en las disjordania
ocupada No han dejado de aumentar la
movilización Palestina comenzó con
manifestaciones contra el desplazamiento
forzoso de familias en el barrio ocupado
en Jerusalén este y acabó desembocando
en una guerra de 11 días entre Israel y
los grupos armados de jamás y la hija
islámica Palestina en la asediada franja
de gaza Mientras tanto en cisjordania
combatientes pales se han reagrupado en
dos nuevos movimientos las brigadas de
jenning y la guardia de los Leones en la
ciudad de naplus estos grupos también
inspiraron a otros eran jóvenes sin
afiliación partidaria y armados que
enfrentaron y atacaron a soldados y a
colonos en sus Jordania 30 israelíes
murieron en 2022 Israel lanzó una
operación denominada romper la ola con
el fin de acabar con esta nueva
resistencia Palestina poco a poco la
operación se convirtió en una represión
masiva cuyos efectos se dieron agravados
por la violencia perpetrada por los
colonos incentivados por la vuelta al
poder de Benjamín netanyahu al frente
del gobierno más derechista de la
historia de Israel desde entonces en
cisjordania los dramas e incidentes y
suceden a diario y la comunidad
internacional parece más impotente que
nunca